so da bin ich wieder leute es wird ernst guck mal
hallo hallo es wird ernst jetzt wird der rechner aufgebaut
wird zeit ist fertig schwer ich hoffe das funktioniert alles
ich hoffe das funktioniert also weniger der rechner der funktioniert das weiß ich hab
schon zusammengestöpselt ich hoffe das funktioniert alles dass ich das
capturen kann ich habe ehrlich gesagt meine zweifel ob da alles ins bild passt
aber das müssen wir gleich mal sehen ich kann die kamera noch ein bisschen
breiter stellen ring light ist direkt so dass es kaum schatten wirft also es
müsste gehen aber normalerweise nehme ich halt so große sachen nicht auf und das
gehäuse ist wirklich riesengroß also da können sich big tower aus den 90er noch
was abschneiden von ja ja ich bin schon wieder da also wie gesagt von der
größe des gehäuses können sich big tower der 90er noch was abschneiden
warte mal ich zeige euch das mal kurz so ihr seht jetzt nicht alles ihr seht
wie weit seht ihr von hier ihr seht von hier also quasi oh nee da fehlt ein
stück bis bis hinten ok das geht ich mache mal die kamera ein bisschen breiter
gucken wir mal ob das was bringt lens ja dass ich mich nicht liege passt schon
ich habe da erst mal nichts was spiegelt großartig ich will lens ultra weit das
ist schon besser oder aber es rauscht ein bisschen das bild aber ihr seht mehr
ihr seht mehr also könnt ihr euch aussuchen entweder rauschiges bild und
weniger sehen oder oder mehr sehen und weniger rauschiges bild
aber ich glaube das geht eigentlich oder also bei mir in der vorschau ist
relativ rauschig aber ich sehe es im stream das geht in der das geht in
der komprimierung fast ein bisschen unter dass das ja ich baue meinen rechner wir
haben ja schon gebaut wir haben ja schon gebaut aber es ist noch nicht alles im
glas leute das gehäuse ist wirklich riesig guck mal hier das ist meine hand
guck mal das ist meine hand seht ihr wie groß das ist das ist meine hand
also das wirklich riesen riesen fettes gehäuse hier unten ist kabel zeug das
muss eigentlich nicht großartig interessieren also das kabel gedönst
dahinter das juckt mich weiter hier unten guck mal hier da kommt das netzteil rein
das seht ihr dann auch da kommt das netzteil hin genau fragt mal chat gpt
ob es man rechner bauen kann so netzteil hier oben wasserkühlung im moment oben
ja das ist oben das ist also das ist die oberseite vom gehäuse wir müssen
gleich mal in den bild guide gucken wie das funktioniert das ist die oberseite
vom gehäuse ja und da kommt halt das mainboard drauf ne leute ich hab schon
ein bisschen geschwitzt weil ich habe erst diese ich habe erst die box nicht
gefunden von fractal design diese box war hier ganz unten ganz unten drin hier
also nicht also hier unten unter der abdeckung noch unten drunter hier
drunter war die box in so einem festplattenkäfig ich dachte erst die
haben das vergessen so und diese box ist halt wichtig weil in der box sind
wer hat sich das schon denken können in der box sind halt schrauben ich weiß
gar nicht ob ihr das überhaupt alles erkennen könnt jetzt weil die ist jetzt
also schärfe ist jetzt nicht die stärke dieser ultra wide things kamera macht
nichts mit dem rausch also wir machen das so wir stellen das größer solange wir
das mainboard bauen wenn wir das mainboard bauen wenn wir das mainboard
bauen können wir so machen weil guck da seht ihr alles hier fängt das mainboard
an ihr seht genau die mainboard area hier so lassen wir das jetzt erstmal fürs
mainboard und für den rest können wir dann ja gucken wir mal also schauen wir
mal ganz kurz rein was uns da an schrauben erwartet ich hab echt nicht
viel platz ich sag jetzt mal jetzt wo ich euch grad wo ich wo ich euch grad da
alle da hab ich probiere das jetzt mal es kann durchaus sein dass es nicht
funktioniert also das setup hier ist eigentlich nicht gedacht für so große
gehäuse selbst mit ihr seht vielleicht ein bisschen wartet mal selbst hier mit
ultra weit das gehäuse geht ja quasi also warte mal ihr seht bis hier das
gehäuse geht noch so ein stück weiter so ein stück hier also quasi ungefähr
ungefähr so lang wie meinen daumen geht es noch mal unten weiter wo ihr das
nicht seht also ist bestimmt noch mal so so 10 15 zentimeter wo es da unten
weitergeht das ist dann halt hier vorne die front vom gehäuse die seht ihr nicht
aber ihr seht ihr seht das komplette mainboard das heißt im endeffekt ich
ich zoome jetzt einfach ran wenn wir das mainboard reinbauen ja das ist
bisschen unverständlich was die da machen so zoomen wir mal ran
lass uns mal ganz kurz gucken was wir hier für schrauben haben ok alle schön
eingepackt auf jeden fall das allerwichtigste ein fractal design
putztuch exzellent das habe ich gebraucht na gut das in der glas scheiben
dabei bei dem gehäuse für für für auf der seite und dann auf der anderen seite
so was haben wir denn wir haben gummi abstandshalter
kabelbinder raum gedöns also ja müsste passen wir gucken jetzt als erstes mal
in das pdf leute wir gucken als erstes mal in das pdf von fractal design und
lassen uns erklären wie man baut
da brauche ich das das pdf
das ist ziemlich das ist so ziemlich das größte gehäuse was man sich kaufen
kann das ist nicht nicht midi das ist kein midi kein midi kann sonst was das
ist das wie gesagt das würde das würde hier big tower der 90er neidisch werden
lassen das ding also die meisten sachen die word verkackt hat können wir nicht
mehr verkacken weil die sache ja schon zusammengebaut ist mal gucken ob wir es
gescheit reinkriegen also das dumme ist halt ich habe jetzt halt die wasserkühlung
aufs mainboard drauf gemacht um es auszuprobieren bevor das gehäuse da war
und das dumme ist halt dass ich irgendwie das mainboard reinlegen muss und dann
die wasserkühlung installieren muss oben mal gucken irgendwie das wird schon
irgendwie hinhauen weil dann noch mal abmachen und neue und neue wärmeleit
passte drauf und so habe ich eigentlich kein bock so wie ich wir brauchen mal wir
brauchen downloads wir brauchen das die hier das handbuch brauchen wir mal also
mashify 2 user guide einfach nur mal gucken dass man sieht was da dabei ist so
bla bla bla bla ok so sieht es aus ja auf die demin auch schon gekommen
ok wasserkühlungs bild alles klar also ja meine grafikkarte hat aber keine
wasserkühlung meine grafikkarte hat einfach nur ganz normale luft luftkühlung
was bin ich hier unten sehend a ssds ok
jeb jeb harn hier kommt das netzteil rein oder soll das das netzteil sein hier
muss das netzteil hier ist netzteil ok was auch immer ich baue oben einfach nur
den radiator ein und die pumpe kommt auf die cpu fertig
mehr habe ich ja net
hat er nicht die slowplug keine ahnung so also das ist anscheinend das was wir
machen wollen also mal das ich muss jetzt mal gucken kurz gucken wie man hier oben
oder oben ist ja
jetzt nicht da da da oben muss hier die wasserkühlung hin
abstandshalter brauchen wir auch ja server bild ok ssd content bock
ssd box contents mounting screws mountings warum gibt es unterschiedliche
mounting screws das sieht mir aus wie die mainboard mounting screw und das
hier ist wahrscheinlich für netzteil an ne das ist power supply drive ok das ist
für die da wann verwendet man was
standoff tool abstandswerkzeug motherboard standoffs cable tie na gut
komplett zu mache ich es erst nach dem stream weil das kann es ja gar nicht
hinstellen gar kein platz für
remove side panels das habe ich schon gemacht das ging erstaunlich einfach
power supply ach soll man damit anfangen ja mit dem power supply ne wir fangen
nicht mit dem power supply an
sehr bescheuert mit dem power supply anzufangen weil das power supply muss ja
kabel reinstecken und die kabel müssen ja hier durch wenn ich es rein stecke kann
ich kabel nicht mehr anmachen das heißt ich mache dieses ganze ding ab was ich
eigentlich nicht vor habe das meshe fei ist sehr nice aber auch sehr groß ok
remove top bracket das brauche ich jetzt gleich weil wasserkühlung und so na ja
habe ich habe ich schon hier guck da schraubchamp ist auch schon am start
wo habe ich ihn hier
ja guckt schraubchamp
er ist schon da den brauchen wir jetzt auch gleich
kein linux techtab schraubendreher ne aber meiner ist besser als der linux techtab
schraubendreher
remove top bracket ja das kriege ich hin das scheint mir nicht so schwierig zu
sein einfach
muss ich das komplett abmachen da komme ich jetzt nicht hin da oben gescheit
ja ich das problem ist ich habe guck mal leute ich habe doch hier gar kein platz
ich kann es hier nicht groß rumdrehen ich muss jetzt versuchen das möglichst zu
ins möglichst alles zu installieren
prepare motherboard ok anscheinend soll ich das oben abmachen install aus schielt
das hat mein mainboard mich das ist alles in einem ok ich muss auf jeden fall
oben alles klar ich muss auf jeden fall oben abmachen ich brauche noch eine
anleitung wie man in der wasserkühlung installiert
reattach top panel optional steps
hard drive cage das juckt mich jetzt erst mal weniger
wie viel platz hast du von den mountlöchern der gpu zum side panel was weiß ich
remove drive cage wo ist denn hier für uns denn hier die anleitung für den für
die wasserkühlung was denn das da kann man noch 2,5 zoll obendrauf machen ok
naja remove top and front panels for easier access
nee das brauche ich nicht wo wo kommt wo ist wasserkühlung muss er
ane grafikkarte install pump unit nein haben wir da keine anleitung hier fan
or radiator space nee das will ich ja oben hin bauen
dr magic dankeschön für den sub also quasi so nur halt dass da oben der
radiator hin soll water cooling radiator options da sind
wir doch 20 genau wir kommen der sache näher
possibly genau das will ich haben das ist hinten das ist oben
na super mehr mehr mehr anleitung gibt es dazu nicht oder was
ja dann müssen wir mal ausprobieren ich dachte da ist eine anleitung dabei wie
das jetzt funktioniert es wird ein bisschen erschwert dadurch
du kannst die du kannst die gpu auch gekippt einbauen ja aber dazu brauchst
du irgendwie in den winkel fürs mainboard oder so weil kannst du auch gekippt einbauen
ok also wartet mal ich ich switch mal kurz um vielleicht hat irgendjemand also ich werde
hier kein risiko eingehen dass ich was kaputt mache wenn ich nicht weiß wie es geht dann
muss ich das muss ich das ohne euch machen hier oben sind das scheint mir relativ simpel
zu sein ich glaube ich muss ich glaube ich muss noch
nicht mal irgendwas abmachen hier sind überall hier sind löcher
ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher wie das funktioniert ehrlich gesagt
also hier oben kann man anscheinend abklipsen das ganze
ok das ist easy gemacht guck mal wir habt ihr gesehen wie einfach das geht da kannst
du dich echt nicht beschweren ich sehe halt nix mein problem ist ich
sehe nix warte mal ich mach das mal kurz raus wir müssen
mal ein stückchen vorziehen also das ist wirklich abenteuerlicher
aufbau ich habe hier unten drunter hier vorne was
drunter gelegt damit ich überhaupt
das hier hinlegen kann da ist nämlich nix drunter normalerweise
und muss ein bisschen platz machen dass ich hinkomme
ok so funktioniert das schon mal nicht da müssen wir noch mal in die anleitung gucken
wie das funktioniert hat ok muss man das einfach nur kippen
easy das wars einfach nur einfach nur genug kippen
fertig ok das war jetzt ziemlich einfach
das gehäuse macht echt gut durchdachten eindruck muss ich sagen
so dann haben wir hier den staubfilter staubfilter
den muss ich wahrscheinlich auch abmachen ja staubfilter
und jetzt kann ich höchstwahrscheinlich dort die wasserkühlung dran machen
weil das hier ist bestandteil vom gehäuse das machst du nicht ab
ok probier mal aus ich hole sie mal wie gesagt leute ich werde kein
ich werde kein risiko eingeben bevor ich was kaputt mache muss ich das leider ohne euch
machen aber bis jetzt siehts ja ganz gut aus
ich hab kein steamdeck ich kann dazu nix sagen
mainboard muss ich eh einbauen weil mainboard und wasserkühlung schon
zusammen sind ich muss mal gucken ich hole jetzt mal das
mainboard und die wasserkühlung das ist richtig fett und schwer alles
dann setz ich das mal ja brauche ich noch abstandshalter
das ist eine gute frage ich mach mal kurz
leute ich mach hier oben mal ein bisschen platz
dass ich im zweifelsfall die wasserkühlung mal temporär hier oben hinlegen kann
hier da bin ich mal nachher gespannt
ich hab fürs netzteil noch keinen adapter gekauft weil es nirgendswo gab außer bei irgendeinem
ebay shop für 40€ gibt doch nicht ein drittel vom netzteil für den grafikkarten adapter
aus ok ich muss euch mal kurz absetzen dass
ich das tragen kann
ich nehme den
Da müsst ihr euch mal angucken, wie fett das Gehäuse ist. Seht ihr das Mainboard? Das Mainboard ist auch nicht klein, ne?
Das geht voll unter in dem Gehäuse. Das ist kein Mini-ITX oder sowas. Richtig fettes Mainboard.
Okay, wo stellen wir das jetzt mal temporär hin? Ich mach mal kurz die übrig gebliebenen Kabels hier mal aus dem Weg.
Ich hab das einfach so abgebaut von dem, was wir letztens im Stream aufgebaut haben.
Das ist übrigens, wo ich erzählt hab, das ist der Stromschalter, der Power-Knopf, den ich seit 15 Jahren von in einem uralt all die Gehäuse rumliegen hab.
Der hat mir echt das Leben gerettet. Klar, ich kann es auch mit einem anderen Schalter machen oder mit einem Schraubendreher überbrücken, aber so ein Schalter ist noch ganz ganz nützlich.
So, das muss so rum rein, wenn ich das richtig gesehen hab, also sprich, das da muss da hinten durch und oben kommt die Wasserkühlung hin.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Das ist natürlich äußerst unhandlich. Alles gerade. Massive unhandlich.
So, Mainboard. Das passt auch halbwegs. Okay, da müssen auch Abstandshalter drunter. Merke ich gerade. Okay, gut.
Nächstes Mal lasse ich mich nicht mehr davon hinreißen, das aufzubauen vor... Nee, da müssen keine Abstandshalter hin. Ist gut, passt alles. Nee, passt auch alles. Alles gut.
Ja, so ist genau richtig. Ja, exellent. Hier, passt. Guck, seht ihr da, die Löcher? Wartet mal, ich mach mal ein bisschen ran.
Guck, seht ihr? Die Löcher oben und unten? Passt genau. Exquisite. Jaja. Und es gibt auch, naja, hier in der Mitte könnte man vielleicht...
Wobei, nee, da ist auch schon einer drunter. Eigentlich ist alles ziemlich optimal. Wir schrauben das Mainboard jetzt einfach mal fest. So, dazu brauchen wir, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Kann die Wasserkühlung nicht abmachen, es sei denn, ich will wieder neue Wärmelite-Paste draufschmieren und sowas. Vielleicht wäre es am Ende einfacher gewesen, aber mal gucken.
So, welche Schrauben brauchen wir denn? 48-fach? Die da wahrscheinlich, ne? Nee. Die da, die da, hier. Letztes Paket. Die da sind es wahrscheinlich, denke ich mal. Ihr seht es nicht richtig, aber die sind wahrscheinlich die richtigen.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob ich da mit meinem Schraubendreher reinpasse. Yep, easy. Gut.
Okay. Machen wir mal hier in der Mitte eins. Hä?
Seht ihr, dass ich die richtigen hab? Sicher, dass ich die richtigen hab?
Ich bin mir jetzt nämlich gar nicht so sicher, ob das die richtigen sind.
Sollten M3 sein? Wartet mal.
Installing Mainboard. Das war doch ganz am Anfang irgendwo. Also, wir haben M3. Die hatte ich eigentlich gerade.
Vielleicht brauchen wir die anderen mit den 20. Lass mal kurz gucken. Installing Mainboard.
Prepare Mainboard.
Jaja, das haben wir schon gemacht.
Haben wir auch schon gemacht.
Ja, brauchen wir anscheinend keinen Abstandshalter. Scheint alles zu funktionieren. Welche Schrauben sind denn das jetzt?
Ah, okay. Siehst du, ich hatte die falschen. Siehst du, ich hatte die falschen Schrauben.
Gut, dass wir das geklärt haben. Dann nehmen wir noch mal die richtigen Schrauben.
Auf, komm mal raus. Wie viel braucht man da so? Machen wir mal zwei Stück erstmal raus.
Okay. Seht ihr was? Ja.
Ja, das ist schon besser.
Ja, jetzt funktioniert das auch. Siehst du mal. Kaum nimmt man die richtigen, schon funktioniert's.
Also wir waren gerade hier an der da. Die habt ihr nicht gesehen, aber die anderen seht ihr wahrscheinlich.
Die machen wir da hinten mal fest.
So, nice. Jetzt haben wir das Mainboard schon mal halbwegs fest.
Ich mach jetzt noch mal eine Schraube rein, dass es fest ist. Ich muss ja nicht jede einzelne Schraube, falls ich es nochmal irgendwie irgendwas umrücken muss oder so.
Ich mach noch hier irgendwo eine rein. Den Rest mach ich nachher fest, weil wer weiß, vielleicht muss ich es ja nochmal abmachen.
Da hab ich natürlich Bock drauf, wieder alles rauszuschrauben dann gleich.
So, gut. Ich mach das Gehäuse ein bisschen weiter hinter, dass ihr besser was seht. Sehr schön.
Ich glaube ich muss noch ein bisschen weiter hier hin machen.
Hallo, hallo hallo. Ihr seht mich, gut.
Und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie die Wasserkühlung da hinten rein kriegen. Hast du das IO Shield drin? Ja, das ist am Mainboard schon dran.
So und jetzt natürlich die große Preisfrage.
Wie rum macht man das dran? So rum oder so rum?
Fuck, scheiße man. Das Ringlight ist im Weg, ich kann das jetzt nicht rumdrehen.
Alles klar.
So und hier kann ich das jetzt irgendwie dran machen. Ich bin mir bloß ehrlich gesagt komplett unschlüssig.
Wie? Ah, easy. Von außen mit den Schrauben oder von der anderen Seite wahrscheinlich.
Schönes Hemd. Keine Ahnung. Moment, ich mach mal kurz Weitwinkel, dass ihr besser was seht.
Jetzt seht ihr noch ein bisschen mehr.
Also seht ihr die Löcher hier oben? Ich denke mal, dass ich hier von außen was reinschrauben muss.
Ich hab noch von diesem Mounting Kit hier was.
Ich denke mal, ich brauch hier von was.
Ich denke mal, ich brauch die Dinger.
Das müssen wir uns mal, da müssen wir uns mal ne Anleitung angucken, ob es da irgendwo was gibt.
Meshify 2, Arctic Freezer Installation oder Montage. Hier, guck mal da. AM4 Kekkel, man.
Gekommert. Das müssen ganz kurze Schrauben sein. Mal gucken, ob es da bildet.
Ich hab sowas noch nie gemacht. Bevor wir da irgendwas sinnlos anschließen.
Exakt so sollte das bei mir auch aussehen dann.
Wir haben es ja prinzipiell alles richtig. Richtige Richtung.
Ich glaube man schraubt das einfach durch und das wars.
Ich glaube man schraubt das einfach von der Seite durch.
Da im Gehäusehandbuch steht nicht so wirklich geiles Zeug. Da wurde man nicht so wirklich schlau draus.
Alter, warum leckten das so?
Ja, das hab ich mir vorhin angeguckt.
Warum leckten das Scheiß so? Warum scrollen?
Guck mal hier, Radiator. Das einzige was man hier sieht ist halt das.
Und das ist halt echt nichts sagen. Ich vermute mal man muss das mit so kleinen Schrauben machen.
Wahrscheinlich mach ich das deutlich komplizierter als es sein müsste.
Wahrscheinlich nennt man einfach die Schrauben.
Dann mach ich das jetzt einfach mal.
Dann mach ich das jetzt einfach mal mit diesen Teilen hier. Guck mal.
Mit denen da.
Ich hab jetzt nichts gefunden ob das stimmt aber das scheint mir die logischste Sache zu sein.
Das hier ist AMD. Das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall nicht.
Und das andere ist ein Abstandshalter. Mehr Sachen hab ich nicht.
Das ist wirklich nett.
Da sind zwei verschiedene Sorten Schrauben drinnen.
Also Gewinde, ihr seht ja hier oben ist gar kein Gewinde.
Wir müssen mal kurz gucken. Wartet mal. Ich muss mal kurz auf die andere Seite gucken.
Mein Headset ist zu kurz. Wartet mal.
Ok ok ich hab's gefunden. Nice. Ich hab's gefunden.
Ich glaub wir brauchen. Ich glaube ich weiß was wir brauchen.
Ich glaube. Leer das mal kurz aus in den Karton.
Guckt mal ich glaube wir brauchen die hier.
Die da brauchen wir glaube ich.
Wir machen eine Unterlegscheibe drunter.
Also wahrscheinlich so hier.
Und ich probier das jetzt einfach mal. Schauen wir mal.
Wo ist denn hier ein Loch?
Oder ist das so gedacht dass man das montieren kann wo man will?
Wahrscheinlich deswegen sind hier die Löcher so.
Ja easy.
Na ok ich hab wenig Platz hier hinten jetzt.
Aber das ist halt Streaming geschuldet gerade.
Irgendwo hängt's ich weiß nicht wo.
Leute ich seh hier hinten nix.
Ich seh hier nix das kann ich nicht im Stream machen.
Ich seh nix das ist nicht möglich.
Ich müsste jetzt alles umbauen alles rumdrehen dass ich das sehe.
Ich kann das nicht umdrehen gescheit.
Dann muss ich alles wieder ach ihr meint das ganze Gehäuse?
Ihr habt recht warum dreh ich nicht das Gehäuse rum?
Das müsste funktionieren da ist nix angeschlossen.
Das müsste tatsächlich funktionieren.
Mach ich mal probier ich mal.
Five head chat high IQ.
Extremely six head time.
Vielleicht kann ich sogar so drehen dass ihr von außen drauf gucken könnt.
Das Ding ist echt schwer man.
Jetzt muss ich noch was drunter legen und das Gehäuse.
Alles gut.
Jetzt solltet ihr gleich was sehen.
Nicht wirklich ihr seht nix.
Guckt mal.
Ich hab's extra einmal schepp gedreht.
Ihr seht nix also hier ist die Wasserkühlung ja und hier sind die Schrauben also.
Ich hab jetzt eigentlich gehofft ihr seht die Schrauben.
Hab ich chat wisst ihr wo ich die Schraube hin hab?
Hier da ist sie.
Okay aber jetzt müsste ich es eigentlich sehen.
Seht ihr was?
Ja nice.
Okay also erste Schraube ist drin.
Das ist dann tatsächlich gar nicht so kompliziert.
Also jetzt ist auch zum ersten mal wirklich der Beweis so das Ding passt ins Gehäuse ohne Probleme.
Das ist kein Define 7 das ist ein Meshify 2 XL.
Leute wir können das gar nicht großartig.
Also man hat hier gar keine großen Möglichkeiten das zu installieren.
Ich muss das im Endeffekt wirklich ganz in die Ecke machen.
Weil weiter gehen die Schläuche hier unten gar nicht.
Die Fitch 90 passt rein.
Das ist eines der größten Gehäuse die es gibt.
Okay dann machen wir die anderen Schrauben.
Also wie viele Schrauben brauchen wir denn hier?
Lass mal kurz checken wir brauchen.
Eins zwei na gut man braucht ja wahrscheinlich nicht alle.
Oh ich hab es am falschen dran gemacht.
Gut zu wissen man muss es noch ein Stückchen höher machen.
Ihr seht es halt nicht das ist halt blöd.
Wartet mal ich drehe euch mal rum vielleicht sieht man das dann besser.
Vielleicht sieht man das besser ich drehe es noch mal ein Stückchen rum.
Schauen wir mal.
Das Gehäuse wiegt schon ein bisschen plus das ganze mit der Wasserkühlung drin.
Vor allem kann ich das nicht richtig heben weil es so groß ist.
Ich muss wirklich aufpassen dass hier nichts umfällt.
Ich habe das auch nur gemacht weil ich euch das versprochen habe.
Normalerweise hätte ich das alleine gebaut.
Ihr seht das seht ihr das hier jetzt?
Nicht wirklich gut oder?
Hier?
Ja ein bisschen ein bisschen seht ihr das.
Hier oben.
Mehr kann ich jetzt nicht machen.
Ich kann euch die Schrauben rein stellen dass ihr was zu gucken habt.
Jetzt muss ich hier mal an meinen Schraubendreher dran kommen.
Also ich mache das noch mal kurz ab.
Ihr seht es gleich wenn ich auf der anderen Seite bin.
So please Unterlegschraube nicht abfallen.
Sieht aber so aus als fällt die jetzt gleich ab.
Hier muss ich hin.
Hier muss ich hin jetzt passt das.
Jetzt habe ich es richtig.
Ok nice, guckt hier.
Chet soll ich es wieder rumdrehen dass ihr von hinten das seht?
Ich glaube da war immer noch besser als gar nichts sehen.
Wartet mal.
Dauert alles 5 mal länger aber gut.
Ich muss aufpassen dass ich nichts kaputt mache.
Langsam ist besser als Zeugs kaputt machen.
Ok.
Schalt um.
Fuß, Hosenlieg.
Seht ihr das?
Jetzt erkennt ihr es halbwegs.
Ok, also jetzt bauen wir uns hier noch ein paar Schrauben zusammen von dem Kram.
Ok.
Es hängt Leute.
Es ist in der richtigen Pose.
Alles gut, guckt mal hier.
Also ich habe jetzt zur Auswahl.
Viel bewegen kann man das halt nicht.
Die zwei Zentimeter hier sind das einzige was ich an Spielraum habe wenn ich das Kabel nicht zu sehr biegen will oder belasten will.
Ich muss es also quasi in der Ecke hier lassen.
Easy.
Ok, jetzt kann ich alles dran schrauben.
Weil es ist hier der Radiator.
Ok alles gut.
Hier unten ist auch Schraube und hier oben.
Ok.
Also ich brauche noch eins, zwei, drei, vier, zehn, zehn solcher Schrauben.
Mache ich da jetzt wirklich alles dran?
Bin ich so, bin ich so?
Ordentlich.
Wir machen erst mal unten noch zwei rein.
So.
Jetzt kommen hier unten noch zwei Schrauben rein.
Gut.
Das können wir tatsächlich schon ein bisschen anziehen.
Weil das kann ich eh nicht weiter bewegen großartig.
Ok, nice, nice, nice, passt.
Gut.
Eine mache ich noch rein?
Nee, ich mache in die Mitte auch noch eine.
Was ich mache, ich mache den Radiator für den Wasserkühler fest.
Äh, da.
So.
Fest ist er.
Wir brauchen noch vier Schrauben, komm, komm, das machen wir jetzt.
Wir machen erst noch vier Schrauben.
Wollen wir mal nicht so sein.
Komm, scheiß drauf.
Wir sind, sind wir nicht so pingelig.
Hier eins.
Eine Schraube.
Zwei Schrauben.
Drei Schrauben.
Ok, Unterlegscheibe.
Eine brauche ich noch, jawoll.
Das finde ich ganz gut.
Die haben es nicht so, oh shit, wo ist die Schraube hin?
Die haben sich so knapp bemessen.
Sondern man kommt da ohne Probleme, hat man genug.
Ach Leute, ich brauche ja gar nicht vier.
Ich habe mich verzählt, keck, ich brauche noch acht.
Wir machen jetzt oben zwei und unten zwei, das reicht.
So.
Jorn4peak, Dankeschön.
Ich sehe es nur, ich sehe es nur aus zwei Meter Entfernung.
Jetzt habe ich die Schraube verkehrt Schäpp reingemacht, guck mal.
Im Eifer des Gefechts.
Weil auch hier der Fuß vom, hier steht der Fuß vom Ringlight, Alter.
Wieder Schäpp, was ist denn das?
Warum ist das Schäpp?
Was ist hier, warum ist das hier Schäpp?
Anzeige ist raus.
Darf nicht Schäpp sein.
Ist die Schraube vielleicht Schäpp?
Nö.
So.
Gut.
Also das ist bombenfest.
Ich mache jetzt da unten noch die Schrauben rein und fertig ist.
Da machst du nichts.
So mal gucken, ob ich hier überhaupt rankomme, weil hier ist nicht viel Platz.
Ich bin wirklich froh, dass ich so einen magnetischen Schrauber habe.
Der Schrauber ist nicht magnetisch, sondern die Spitzen sind alle schön magnetisch.
So, Wasserkühlung ist installiert.
Nice.
Gut.
Da kann ich das erste Mal erstmal entsorgen und aus dem Weg räumen, weil ich blicke hier
fast schon immer durch.
Viel zu viel Zeug, halbe Zimmer steht voll mit, voll mit Kram.
Gut.
Die Lüfter hört man im Volllast, hört man die Lüfter, aber ansonsten nicht.
So, ich drehe euch mal wieder um.
Ich drehe euch mal wieder um in die sinnvolle Posi, sodass ihr wieder alles seht und die
Wasserkühlung und alles.
Fuck, ist das schwer, das Teilband.
Okay, gut, da sind wir wieder.
So, ich gucke, ob ich euch mal ein bisschen ranzoomen kann.
So, wir sind am Start, Wasserkühlung ist drin, montiert auf der CPU ist es schon.
Das Mounting Bracket, was da drinnen rumliegt, braucht hier nicht rumliegen.
Gut, also, jetzt kommt als nächstes, den Power Button kann ich wieder abmachen.
Die Füße vom Gehäuse sind ein bisschen schepp, aber okay.
So, Wasserkühlung ist installiert, Lüfter sind noch nicht dran, okay, Netzteil würde
ich sagen.
Ich muss mal kurz in mich gehen, ob ich noch mehr Netzteilsachen brauche, als die, die
ich vorher schon dran hatte.
Ich mache noch mal kurz Widescreen, also, eigentlich nicht, doch, doch, doch, doch, doch,
die Grafikkarte Leute, die Grafikkarte fehlt doch noch, ich kacke Noob, das wichtigste
habe ich vergessen, die Grafikkarte muss doch noch, die Grafikkarte müssen wir noch
machen, der Trümmer, genau, okay, dann müssen wir mal gucken, wie wir die gemountet kriegen
gescheit, steht dazu was im Handbuch, doch, doch LED's, jede Menge LED's, hier oben stand
auch Mount-GPU drinnen, ja, Hochkant-Placement, Nopaz, was machen die hier, Trace, schein mir
recht modular zu sein, das Gehäuse, finde ich eigentlich ganz nice, ja, install-Grafikkarte,
ja, das ist, mach mal Ausrufezeichen PC, dann siehst du, was das für eine Zusammenstellung
ist, ja, super, man soll die Grafikkarte reinstecken, auf die Idee wäre ich auch schon gekommen,
High IQ Handbuch, okay, Leute, ich hol mal kurz die, ich hol mal kurz die Grafikkarte,
ich muss die nicht holen, die steht ja hier quasi neben mir, das hier ist die Verpackung,
die wollen wir nicht, hier ist die Festplatte, die brauchen wir jetzt auch nicht, ich hab
dieses komische Ding, hier bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, was man damit machen soll, ist
sie vielleicht, wenn ich es hochkant montieren will, oder, oder macht man das an irgendeinen
Slot unten drunter, oder, Stütze für hinten, okay, aber wo macht man die dran, hm, bin ich
jetzt gerade, also man müsste die ja im Endeffekt sind irgendwie, ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wie
man das, also man die Grafikkarte ist dann im Endeffekt hier so drauf, aber ich meine,
da gibt es ja nichts zum Festschrauben oder so, außerdem müsste ich das ja irgendwie
so, nein, das stützt einfach nur am Boden des Gehäuses, das klemmt zwischen GPU und
Boden, what, das bringt dann was, okay probieren wir mal aus, ich bau das jetzt mal ein, okay,
gut, was ist denn das hier eigentlich, USB-C onboard, oder was ist das hier, USB-C, steht
sogar dran, okay wo ist die Grafikkarte, komm her, dickes Teil, gachibus, boah, kurz aus
der, aus der Verpackung holen, alter was ein Ding man, ich rüchte es mal an, was passt
hier gar nicht drauf, Alter, oh da ist, Moment, da ist noch, da ist, da ist noch Plastik drauf,
guck mal, was ist das, GeForce, Highpower, achso, man soll darauf achten, dass alles
richtig drinne ist, jaja, ich achte darauf, dass alles richtig drinne ist, ist gut, wir
wollen ja nicht, dass es anfängt zu brennen, okay mal kurz das Ding ab, Alter, kann man
sich eigentlich ablegen, ja, also wir müssen jetzt erstmal hier das Slotplech raus machen,
da habe ich keinen Platz, weil die Kamera drüber ist, nice, muss ich mal einen kleineren
Schraubendreher holen, mal gucken ob der geht, welches brauchen wir überhaupt, welchen Slot
brauchen wir den hier, den da Chat, oder den da, ach ihr seht das nicht richtig, ne, da
ist der Chat da vor, Alter, jetzt habe ich das Ding quer durch den Raum gepfeffert, muss
ich unter den Tisch das Teil rausholen, man, MonkaGiga, oh, wo habe ich mich geleakt, habe
ich meinen Kopf geleakt oder so, habe ich, Chat, Chat, habe ich meinen Kopf geleakt irgendwo,
so, also was als nächstes, ja, wo denn, Reflektion im Lüfter, oh nein, also ich glaube wir brauchen
auf jeden Fall 3 Slots für das Ding, anders wird es nicht funktionieren, wieso kommt
die GPU nicht als letztes, was fehlt ja noch, außer der GPU, Postchamp, so, ich denke mal
wir brauchen 3 Slots, oder, ja, da stand was von 3, stand da nicht sogar 3,5 Slots, warte
mal, jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken, welche Kabel, welche Kabel, ach Frontstecker und sowas,
ja stimmt, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht, oh fuck, wo kommen die Frontstecker, ja gut
Frontstecker kann ich nachher immer noch machen, wo kommen, wo kommen die Frontstecker überhaupt
her, hier, das Mainboard ist fest, doch doch das Mainboard ist fest, Slotplech, ich komme
noch nicht dran, ich komme noch nicht dran, das muss hier oben, wo muss das überhaupt
hin, hier unten, Quatsch, das ist überhaupt kein Ding, easy, hier unten kommt das ganze
dran, hier unten in die Ecke, da, da in die Ecke ist das, das ist kein Ding, das passt,
macht euch da mal keine Gedanken, Keckel, Famous, Famous Last Words, ich weiß, naja,
machen jetzt die Grafikkarte ein, so wieviel Slots brauchen wir denn, 3 oder 3,5, Zotac,
zuerst das Ding, OC, 40,90, Slots, Slot, technische Daten, 3,5 Slots, ok Chat, meine dofe Frage,
was heißt denn 3,5 Slots, ich muss 4 Slotplatten abmachen oder 3, das heißt 4, der Chat ist
sich nicht ganz einig, es sind 3, es sind 3, 3,5 ist es nur wegen dem Lüfter obendrauf,
nein, nein, gehst du mal weg, Kabel, Kabel, weg hier, weg, ja Kabel, geh da zwischen hier,
ok, fettes Teil wird eingesetzt, Gachibus, boah alter Mann, ich seh nix, ich seh gar
nix, das ist zu groß, ich seh nix, ist das jetzt drin, es ist, ich seh nix, das ist ja
reudig alter, ich glaube es ist drin, ist es drin, ja das ist kacke, ich seh nix, ich
muss mal kurz, ich hab da keinen Platz, ich komm da nicht hin, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
wirklich richtig ätzend hier, ich hab überhaupt keinen Platz, ok, jetzt kann ich mal kurz
das Ding vorziehen und gucken ob ich, ob ich es richtig drinne hab, ja, ja, ja sieht drinne
aus, ah, sieht so aus, ah so gut, vielleicht erkennt man es hier von der Seite besser,
krass alter, man sieht nix, es ist das, der Aufbau ist so scheiße hier, ich seh nix man,
das Ding ist halt mega fett, also ich glaube es ist drinne, sonst wird es jetzt hier auch
richtig reingehen und flach auflegen, chat als machen es hier, guck mal hier ist ne Schraube,
hier fehlt ne Schraube, hier fehlt ne Schraube und irgendwo da hinten fehlt ne Schraube,
who cares jetzt alter, das ist jetzt, als macht es das jetzt fett, so und was genau
soll das hier jetzt werden wenn es fertig ist, wartet mal, hä und was soll man damit
jetzt machen?
Du kannst die Schraube
auf dem Boden, wo das Netzteil ist, das Netzteil ist da, so oder wie oder what?
So oder, hätt, nä oder, so hier oder wie, das kann doch nicht in den Ernst sein, das
hängt ja dann halb im, das hängt ja dann halb im Lüfter drin, also so hier oder was,
ihr sehts nicht, das ist zu kurz die Kamera, also quasi hier unten mal, also ich zeig
es euch mal so stellvertretend hier, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass es halt nicht dahin
muss, sondern, sondern da hinten, aha aha, zumindest gar nicht bewusst gegeben, dass
es sowas, bewusst gewesen, dass es sowas tatsächlich gibt, die Füße sind hier unten
drunter, so jetzt brauchen wir noch ein Kabel für dieses Ding hier, wir machen die Grafikkarte
noch mal oben fest jetzt, falls ich da, falls ich da hinkomm, das ist wirklich, wirklich
PP-Gastell hier.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt da mit dem Schraubendreher gescheit rein, aber ich komm
nicht hin, weil die Kamera direkt hier oben drüber hängt, das heißt ich kann das nur
mit dem, nur mit dem kleinen machen, weil ansonsten ist kein Platz, gucken ob ich vielleicht
doch da reinkomme, aber ich glaub das ist zu groß oder, he, gerade, ganz knapp, ganz
knapp Leute, ok jetzt ist das Teil ordentlich fest, boah, das ist, man das ist aber auch
ein fettes Teil man, ja kein Wunder, dass die da hinten was haben, was, was, was dagegen
drückt, ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken, wie man so, wie man so einen Halter einbaut, GPU,
wie heißt denn das, äh, Halte, Halterung oder sowas, da zum Beispiel, pass auf das
ist jetzt ein Rickroll-Video, Grafikkarte hängt durch, ja, what the, was, was, was
ist das, ok, ok, ok, ja, ja, ich glaube ich, ich glaube ich hab's im Prinzip gecheckt,
man macht das im Endeffekt, also jetzt nicht hier, sondern unten, macht man das hier so
drunter, guckt, so, achso ihr seht ja gar nix, so, so seh, also wie gesagt nicht so,
sondern halt an der anderen Stelle, würde man das drunter machen, aber so sinngemäß,
so steckt man das dann drunter, halt nicht da, sondern da, hinten und andersrum wahrscheinlich,
aber das ist, dass die Grafikkarte nicht absackt, ok, na gut, wir wollen ja nicht, dass die
Grafikkarte absackt, gatschi, was, Bässe, wobei ich nicht glaube, dass die so krass
durchhängt, ok, also wo ist jetzt, wo ist das geile Stromkabel hin, ja Leute ich schraub
das schon fest bevor ich das hinstelle, hinstellen kann ichs hier eh nicht, ok, ich würd jetzt
ja gerne noch mal nen Blick reinwerfen ob wirklich alles fest ist, dumm ist ich seh
nix, ohne dass ichs irgendwie, ja, ey keine Chance da jetzt noch dran zu kommen gescheit,
ich muss das runterheben und reingucken, so Sinem was willst du mir eigentlich sagen,
meinst du das Ding implodiert jetzt weils da liegt oder was, vom liegen oder wie, muss
das glaub ich runterheben und mal reingucken ob das alles richtig dran ist, ja wie gesagt
ich glaube nicht, dass die so richtig durchhängt, ich hab ja schon mal ein bisschen dran gezogen,
also nicht so krass wie in dem Video eben, ich muss das Ding jetzt runterheben und mal
reingucken ob alles fest ist, ja obs durchhängt, obs durchhängt probier ich, das ist mal kurz
das ist die passende dramatische Musik dazu, wartet mal ich schau mal kurz die Musik,
ich stelle es mal kurz auf den Boden, ich schau mal kurz die Musik, ich schau mal kurz
die Musik, man hat keine Chance, das ist ja geil, man hat echt keine Chance da drin
noch was zu erkennen, man hat echt keine Chance da drin noch was zu erkennen, so voll ist das,
ich muss den Kram noch richtig festschrauben, ja jetzt kann ich wenigstens dran, das muss
ich jetzt mal kurz machen, wenn ich ordentlich dran komme und jetzt kann ich auch das Mainboard
festschrauben, bevor der Chat noch irgendwie Herzinfarkt kriegt, so jetzt komm ich nämlich
auch ordentlich dran, so ich hab 4 Schrauben dran gemacht, erzählt kein Mist Leute, außerdem
was soll ihm liegen denn großartig passieren, erklärt mir das mal sinnvoll, was soll ihm
liegen ordentlich passieren, wenn da nur 4 Schrauben von 9 drin sind, das wackelt nicht,
das kann sich nicht biegen, was soll passieren man, das lag nicht ohne Schrauben, achso ja
am Anfang als ich reingesetzt hab, na klar, ne aber es ist, ok funktioniert, also ich
hab jetzt die Grafikkarte richtig fest, ich nehm jetzt noch mal eine von den Schrauben
und mach das in die Mitte rein, weil ansonsten kommt man da nicht richtig dran, wo hab ich
den, ah hier, hier sind die Schrauben ok, mach gleich wieder Kamera, aber ich muss erst
mal kurz gucken, genau als ich das Case noch gar nicht hatte, lag das einfach auf dem Tisch
und es ist einfach nix passiert, was soll passieren, gut ok, so ich stells wieder hoch
und mach eure Kamera an, jetzt hab ich auch geguckt, dass alles drinne ist, also jetzt
muss man sich da keine Gedanken mehr machen, ich hatte nämlich ein bisschen Angst, dass
es nicht richtig im PCI Express Slot drinne hängt, aber oh, alter ist das schwer das
Ding man, also heute bin ich zwar keine zwei Stunden gelaufen, aber es reicht trotzdem,
die Herausforderung ist halt, dass ich nix sehe, gut also jetzt ist es dran, jetzt kann
ich noch, dass der Chat sich freut, die verbleibenden Schrauben rein machen, morgen Muskelkarte,
ey das kann tatsächlich sein, was habt ihr denn eigentlich alles für Schmerzen, was
genau ist euer Problem, ich mein, das Ding liegt einfach seitlich da, was soll dann passieren,
was genau soll passieren, wenn das Ding seitlich da liegt, das konnte mir bis jetzt noch keiner
irgendwie sinnvoll erklären, der Sinn dahinter, warum ich es vorher nicht festgeschraubt hab,
ist ganz einfach, falls ich noch irgendwas dran ändern muss, muss ich nicht wieder alles
abschrauben, so wo fehlt denn jetzt noch was, Erdbeben, ja, ok wo fehlt denn, seht ihr
noch eine, ne hier ist nehm ich drin, hier ist noch eine, hier haben wir noch eine,
haben wir sonst noch was, ich zoom mal kurz ran, dass ihr besser backseaten könnt, da
ist alles drin, ah hier hinter dem M2-Slot ist noch eine, aha aha, spotted Leute, spotted,
ja das seht ihr, ich seh das nicht, ich stehe ja in dem Winkel hier, guck, also ich seh
das hinter der Grafik, pass mal auf, ich muss das jetzt wieder Zahnarzt machen, wieder Zahnarzt
über, über das Bild, oh fuck jetzt bin ich im Bild, über die Sonde muss ich das machen,
bin ich drin, chat, gachi, nein, ne nicht, ne das ist gar keiner, warte das ist, da ist
kein Loch, das ist ein Standoff vom Case, das sieht man aber nicht richtig, da haben wir
es doch alles, so chat, habt ihr jetzt ernsthaft wegen zwei Schrauben hier den Weltuntergang
prophezeit oder was, seriously, ah ne da hinten, guck mal da hinten ist noch eine, da ist noch
eine, ich seh den nicht, da hinten ist noch eine, hinten hinten ist noch eine, so jetzt
haben wir alles drin, nice, guck noch mal kurz, ah ne, haha ich hab nix gesagt, eine
ist noch, Leute ich muss kurz mein Headset entwirren, dass das funktioniert, ne ich hab
nie so einfach zusammengebaut, die kauft man sich normalerweise fertig, zumal der Unterschied
ist ja, was ihr vergesst, ich seh hier nix, wenn ich das Ding auf dem Boden liegen hätte
und könnte da 360 Grad rumlaufen, dann wär das alles kein Problem, ihr seht wahrscheinlich
besser als ich, genau eins, eins hat noch gefehlt hier, ich glaube wenn ich das richtig gesehen
hab, jetzt stellen die Leute wieder fest, ich hab ne Katze, gut, jetzt ist alles fest,
meine Grafiker ist das keine Blende über den Kabeln oder, die hängt einfach so rum,
wir nehmen das da, ja das gehört so, da ist nix dabei, gut also das hier ist das Stromkabel
für die Wasserkühlung, das ist das RGB Kabel für die Wasserkühlung, ok eigentlich fehlt
jetzt nur noch das Kabel für die Grafikkarte, wenn ich das jetzt, ach ne Moment da ich bin
ja blöd, guck mal, keck wait, keck wait, wie komm ich denn da dran, wait a minute, wie
komm ich, äh, ah, oh ne, hätt ich das mal auf der Erde gemacht, ich snoop, guck mal
seht ihr das hier unten, hier unten sind die Kabel fürs Gehäuse, ich muss noch mal auf
die Erde legen, oder, oder, ah, ah, ah Moment, Moment, sag mal nichts, sag mal nichts, ne,
das könnte, das könnte hinhauen, das könnte hinhauen, wo muss denn der Kram überhaupt
dran, da ne, ach ja, ach ja, da ist noch so was dabei gewesen, da ist noch so was dabei
gewesen, guck mal, damit kann man glaube ich, sich nicht so sehr vertun, ich stell das nicht
auf, das bleibt, das bleibt liegen erstmal, damit kann man sich eben nicht mal so sehr
vertun, wie man was, wie man was reinsteckt, probieren wir mal aus, also das ist aber ein
Adapter von Gigabyte, also die müssten es eigentlich wissen, also wahrscheinlich, warte
mal, wahrscheinlich so, ah, und was genau ist, ach ihr seht das gar nicht, oder, doch
ihr habt es gesehen, was genau ist, Moment, das muss ich euch mal ranzoomen, was ist daran
jetzt besser, ah ihr seht sie, also, ich mein das macht jetzt ja nicht wirklich einen Unterschied
mit diesem Ding, ok doch, du hast, du hast hier vorne ne Aufschrift, was es ist, anstatt
das du auf dem Mainboard, also warte mal, du hast hier, alo, please fokussieren iPhone,
iPhone, fokuss, du hast hier vorne ne Aufschrift anstatt, weiss ich nicht, ob man das braucht,
ich muss jetzt erstmal gucken, dass ich die Kabel irgendwie da rein krieg, ach du steckst
erst die ganzen Kabel da rein, ah, verstehe, verstehe, verstehe, eigentlich müsste ich
es rumdrehen, ich habe aber kein Bock es rumzudrehen, weil da muss ich es wieder runterheben vom
Tisch machen, krieg ich den Kram hier nicht irgendwie so durch, wir machen das mal anders
Leute, wir machen das anders, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal ab, easy, easy, easy, guter
RAM, ja mal gucken ob der RAM so gut ist, easy, ich hab's, ich hab's, haben wir hier
Lüfter, Lüfter, USB, das brauch ich nicht, ich brauch Power, Power, SW, was ist das,
das ist Audio, brauch ich nicht, ja dann ist es einfach, das muss ich dann machen wenn
ich das Gehäuse umdrehe, das mach ich jetzt nicht, ich will es jetzt eigentlich nur mal
einschalten und gucken ob alles funktioniert, wartet mal dazu müssen wir den Kram mal testweise,
ja komm mal her, da haben wir es doch, also was ist was, das hier ist Power-LED, haben
wir hier Power-LED, erkennt man das, Power-LED und das hier ist Power-SW und Reset, Moment,
Power-SW und Reset-SW, Ultrawide, jetzt erkennt man ein bisschen mehr, da mach ich erst einmal
die Power Sachen dran, der Rest ist doch jetzt zum ausprobieren erstmal nicht so relevant,
also wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, jetzt müsste man das mal irgendwie vergrößern,
mal gucken ob das, ah ne man sieht man hier irgendwie die Beschriftung, Moment, Moment,
Enhanced, ah ne, das sieht man von da aus nicht, ok dann nicht, ja weil das ist so klein
ich erkenne das von hier oben aus nicht, Boomer Augen, Boomer Augen, Power-SW, ich glaub so
war das hier, wir gucken einfach nochmal ins Handbuch, wir gucken nochmal ins Handbuch wann
das sein wird, Handbuch, ach ne Moment, Gigabyte Z97 Elite AX, Spezifikationen und ne Unterstützung,
jetzt haben wir die Seite auf Deutsch, ja ach ihr seht es nicht, vorne sind also aktuell
sind 2 Lüfter drinnen, vorne, die kann man entweder unten platzieren oder oben oder oben
und unten und Mitte oder wie auch immer und hinten ist aktuell ein Lüfter drin, mal gucken
wenn das nicht ausreicht kaufe ich mir einfach noch 2 Stück, Handbuch, Handbuch, ja Moment,
F-Panel, ja F-Panel, F-Panel und wie wird es angeschlossen auf dem F-Panel, Alter wirklich,
sagt falls ich zu weit scrolle, Seite 26, ok, Chat kennt sich aus, eh CPU, Fan, ok,
X26, Gigabyte und mich, ja F-Panel hieß das Ding, Seite 29 fast, also ja Power Switch hab
ich richtig angeschlossen und Reset Switch ist direkt unten drunter, ok das ist easy,
die 2 Sachen schließen wir zumindest mal an, Reset und Power, gut, sehr schön, so jetzt
brauchen wir noch Strom für die Grafikkarte, da muss ich mal ins Netzteil gucken, was wir
da an Kabel noch haben, was brauchen wir da noch, das da, VGA, ne welche Anschlüsse
braucht man dafür, das sind 8 PIN, genau das ist der Adapter, also sind sie 8 PIN Dinger,
also brauchen wir quasi noch 8 PIN VGA, was ist das hier, VGA, das da brauchen wir oder,
boah krass sehe ich das richtig, ich brauch vom Netzteil tatsächlich noch 2 weitere Kabel
für diesen Anschlussding hier, heftig, ok ich kauf mir doch den Adapter, ich kauf mir
doch den Adapter, das ist ja abfuck man, das ist ja das zu viel, das ist gut ne, ok und
jetzt muss man gucken, dass der Adapter auch wirklich schön fest drinnen sitzt, sonst
gibt's Monka Smoke, Blö, Monka Abfackel gibt's sonst, ok das erste ist drin, ok das
erste ist drin, oh, oh, erstes haben wir, nächstes, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
unter den schreibtisch stelle muss da noch der adapter dran weil so ist das ja komplett für
den arsch geflügel was ein geflügel das da reinzukriegen mann gut guckt euch guckt euch
dieses hässliche ding mal an alda keck wait mann ok so jetzt müssen wir irgendwie zum irgendwie zum
netzteil runter das netzteil kommt ja da müsste ich das ist jetzt halt doof ne normalerweise
müsste ich das ding jetzt also normalerweise möchte die kabel hier durch machen hier hinten
runter machen unten ans netzteil dran machen das dumme ist nur ich will das jetzt nicht rumheben
ich habe das ich das reicht mir jetzt hier das hoch und runter vom tisch schon ich würde das
ding jetzt gerne mal einschalten und gucken ob prinzipiell alles funktioniert kriegt man das
hier nicht irgendwie temporär mal durch dass ich es anschließen kann zumindest jetzt einfach
ich mein ich kann doch einfach mal hier rein stellen und einschalten nicht dass es jetzt einen
großen unterschied macht haben wir überhaupt noch hier oben auf den einschalter gibt es da
oben noch auch wenn ich die oberseite abhab ok weißt du was ich will einfach mal gucken ob alles
funktioniert bevor ich jetzt komplett zumache das probieren wir jetzt aus wahrscheinlich erzählen
wir die leute wieder oh nein dann stürzt ein haus ein wenn das netzteil zum ausprobieren
hier drinne steht oder wird doch wird doch so sein da wird mindestens das haus einstürzen haarrisse
im haus gibt es hast du dann auch alle schrauben beim netzteil dran gemacht ja klar wenn sie im
gehäuse steht natürlich ok ich stöpsel es jetzt mal dran dann schalten wir ein und gucken ob es
funktioniert clips clips
das finde ich gut an diesen netzteil du kannst eigentlich gar nichts außer ein bisschen staub
du kannst eigentlich gar nichts großartig verkehrt anschließen hier dran gleich blackout ja dann
was ich leute anzeige direkt ok wir müssen nur gucken dass die lüfter frei sind oben alter
dieses ding man sagt mal blöde frage wenn ich einfach nur einschalten will grafikkarten gehen
doch in so einem minimal modus auch ohne strom kabel die können sich doch irgendwie bis 160
watt aus dem pizzi express ziehen oder ist das bei der generation nicht mehr so dass die angehen
ohne strom kabel läuft nicht ok ja da muss ich die dinge jetzt noch ans netzteil anschließen
zack
zack ok es ist alles richtig dritte
vom einschalten muss man natürlich gucken dass die kabel hier nicht in der kühlung hängen das
ist ziemlich er sonst ziemlich blöd wie gesagt bevor man das weil das komplett zumachen kann
ich im stream nicht machen das ist halt das doofe lief es schon ohne grafiker ja sogar
schon übertaktet und alles prinzipiell funktioniert das ja weil das ich muss das ich muss die kabel
hinten rum machen da muss ich jetzt jedes mal für jeden schritt muss ich das runter stellen
hochheben borne da dreh ich durch bei ok jetzt kommt dieses ding hier mann guckt euch das mal
an alter und das ist der wo man aufpassen muss dass er nicht so sehr gebogen ist oder ist das
geht das noch so oder ist das schon wie warum kommt das überhaupt rein so rum jetzt weiß
ich warum die leute das gar nicht richtig rein stecken können jetzt weiß ich dass das ist
nämlich richtig scheiße rein zu stecken fest jetzt hat es klipp gemacht jetzt hat es klick
gemacht das ist aber dumme konstruktion das ist wirklich das ist wirklich richtig das
wirklich richtig richtig richtig dumme konstruktion ok aber es ist ist alles drin ja mehr geht
nicht ok ist das jetzt schon zu viel gebogen leute ist das jetzt schon zu viel gebogen
hältst du aus weil ich mein im gehäuse wird es ja dann wahrscheinlich auch ungefähr so
sein das ist aber wirklich ziemlich ziemlich hängen geblieben hängen gebliebenen konstruktion
ich kaufe mir für das netzteil noch den adapter so ist das so ist das wirklich richtig richtig
dumm soll lüfter bewegen sich alles gut strom kabel
ok dreht sich noch alles gut ok ich mache mal an schauen wir mal ob es funktioniert
leute und meint ihr blackout in ganz deutschland jetzt oder es funktioniert auch ich habe
den rgb stecker für die grafikkarte vergessen fack wo muss denn der rein wo muss der rein
wenn jetzt einer sagt an der unterseite kotze ich da da muss der rein oder wie alle wie
soll man denn da dran kommen wenn ich muss mal kurz ins handbuch gucken lass mich mal
kurz ins handbuch schauen so tech hatten wir das hatten wir das handbuch von der grafikkarte
überhaupt schon offen das ist das handbuch geil da weißt du bescheid es ist sehr gut
lesbar warum hat es einen separaten rgb stecker dass
du es über das mainboard steuern kannst ja gut macht das gehäuse auf alles klar wie
ernsthaft es ist jetzt euer es ist euer fucking ernst ja das ist das handbuch das ist angeblich
das handbuch leute ja das ist ein quick quickstart geil aber das ist lauter in das handbuch so
so tech manual guck mal mal vielleicht gibt es das in deutschland pdf downloads
user manual ne das sieht so kacke aus was da erklärt werden soll na zum beispiel wo
der anschluss für das rgb kabel ist wäre schon mal was das ist relativ sicher das ding
hier da brauche ich eine verlängerung für also ich denke mal hier muss es rein ok das
ist maximal hängen geblieben man das da brauche ich eine verlängerung für da passt das
passt so gar nicht aufs mainboard drauf guck mal also ihr seht ja gar nichts lull moment
wartet mal
das kann ich so gar nicht ins mainboard stecken da brauche ich einen adapter ja die grafikkarte
leuchtet aber die steuerung geht hier drüber guck das muss anscheiden die grafikkarte rein
und das muss ins mainboard rein aber das geht nicht weil ich keine adapter habe um das auf
mainboard zu stöpseln sowas könnte man ja annehmen ist bei einem mainboard dabei könnte
man meinen aber nein nein nein bei diesem mainboard ist quasi nix dabei ich zeige euch
mal kurz was da mitgeliefert wurde ne kurzei ging nicht ich zeige euch mal was da mitgeliefert
wurde steht das nicht immer am anfang box content seite 7 hier sata kabels 1g connector
moment ist das vielleicht einer soll ich noch mal in die packung gucken was ist denn
ein g connector g connector ach nee dieses teil man ja das habe ich das habe ich gefunden
sonst ist da nix dabei ok wir schalten mal ein leute jetzt ist die zeit zeit ist reif
wir schalten ein wenn es kam aber bei einem 340 euro und 2.200 euro grafikkarte nicht erwarten
dass sie irgendwas mit mit liefern oder so ne ist ausgeschlossen nicht nicht im scope
du kannst weitere rgb geräte anschließen achso kann ich die grafikkarte auch dann kann
ich die grafikkarte auch so steuern ohne den kram das kann natürlich auch sein so netz
teil ist aus ok alles klar leute ich muss ich mache die beleuchtung kurz aus dass man
ordentlich was sieht beleuchtungs champ umfrage für was ach quatsch ja mach ne umfrage mords
wenn ihr bock hat macht ne umfrage oh jetzt ist sack dunkel kein bock gut dann lass es
bleiben ok mal kurz kurz anlassen muss ich alles klar ich mache an ich habe jetzt nix
gesehen habe ich überhaupt eingeschaltet ich sehe nix moment ich muss nochmal licht
anmachen ich sehe nix was los ok so netz teil netz teil ist an strom ist an aber strom ist
nicht richtig drin glaube ich doch strom ist richtig drin alter das ist so kacke da kommste
jetzt hängt das wieder hier unten am lüfter mann ist ein abfuck wo ist denn jetzt die
rgb geschichte doch doch netz stecke also ist alles drin aber wie gesagt genau das gleich
hatte ich letztens schonmal dass der on board button hier auch beispielsweise nicht funktioniert
hat ich weiß halt auch nicht ob der stecker dafür dran ist wo hab ich mein wo hab ich
mein button hin fack wo hab ich den button hingeschmissen leute seht ihr das teil irgendwo
hier power button ist eigentlich alles da müsste müsste da sein ich weiß ja nicht
ob hinten alles angeschlossen ist weißt du was wir machen noch mal kurz aus dran ist alles
wo waren denn noch mal die rgb leds dass man sieht ob es an ist da da ok ok ok ja ich glaube
dass es könnte hinten vielleicht nicht verbunden sein scheiß drauf also ich mach mal ich mach
mal wieder mein ja wie rum der button das ist egal ich mach mal wieder mein magic button
aus dem all die pc von 2000 2005 dran der geht immer
ich irgendwas verkehrt dran
netz teil näher netz teil ist eigentlich ok habe ich irgendwas nicht richtig reingesteckt
oder so wollte eigentlich nur testen ob es geht bevor ich es
habe keine ahnung ich habe keine ahnung das muss irgendwas simples sein ja es liegt bestimmt
an den schrauben ja vielleicht habe ich es auch kann das sein dass es hinten nicht richtig
auf dem board dran ist jaja das kann sein weil das hatte ich vorhin ab
bin ich aber echt bis bisschen ratlos
zeit fürs multimeter man das ist jetzt halt scheiße weil ich sehe hier nix gescheit man
als so abfuck also dran ist eigentlich alles dran ist alles drin ist alles ja ok jetzt ist
wahrscheinlich die zeit gekommen wo ich es nicht im stream fertig machen kann weil ich
das geuse runter stellen muss und mal dran muss also ich wüsste jetzt nicht was da noch
großartig sein sollte das war nämlich alles vorher schon noch vom letzten stream drinne
also insofern das frontpanel ist falsch belegt nähe ich sehe ja auch dass es kein strom kriegt
hier an den leds aber ich hatte es wie gesagt ich hatte gestern genau das gleiche ich hatte
gestern genau das gleiche dass es nicht anging nachdem ich es vom strom weg habe gestern
war es der power button der nicht funktioniert das es gibt noch nicht mal strom auf mainboard
das ist sehr sehr merkwürdig bin ich jetzt bin ich verwirrt gigabyte ja oh nähe ich
will jetzt die grafikkarte nicht ausbauen man abfuck so ein rotz was das hier pc express
alles klar
ich mach das ding mal weg das netz teil hat kein rappel das ging gestern alles nähe das
ist ich werde mir jetzt was super simples wahrscheinlich scheinlich irgendwo nicht richtig
drinnen oder sonst was das wird nix das wird nix großartig komplizierter sein ja ich bin
mal ich relativ sicher weil was soll sein großartig um an jetzt muss die grafikkarte
wieder ausbauen habe ich überhaupt kein bock drauf ich habe was sie eingesteckt ja das
denke ich auch ich ich komme bloß nicht richtig dran gerade wieder ausbauen please muss es
sein das ist ja leute deswegen schraube ich die sachen nicht richtig fest jetzt habe ich
mal richtig fest geschraubt jetzt muss ich ausbauen geil oder poc or not poc not poc
eher not poc komme halt nicht richtig hin
hoffe ich habe euch jetzt nicht geschlagen quasi mit dem ich hätte das ding einschalten
soll noch mal als auf dem tisch gelegen hat von gestern kriege ich das so raus so ich
bin echt gespannt wo das problem ist
so grafikkarte wieder raus da hat polle glaube ich auch nicht dass man die gpu wirklich ausbauen
ist aber es ist mir lieber da kann ich das ding nämlich auch ein bisschen rumheben ok
wo ist dieser komische klebser da ok achtung und meine güte ich sehe nix jetzt
das ist ein fetter style man ok was genau ist jetzt das problem liebes mainboard das
ist dran das ist dran alles dran netzteil habe ich hier alles richtig drinne e8 anas
da kannst du es ja nicht dran machen
ssd ist drin ja ok also drin ist eigentlich alles
ich habe jetzt echt keine ahnung mehr mein stromkabel ist ob obviously drinne ich müsste
mal mein strommessgerät einstöpseln falls ich da hinkomme warte mal ich mache mal hier
den stromkabel vom handy raus und das andere stromkabel dran bios reset das geht ja noch
nicht mal an alter chat soll ich dann bios reset machen
der war schon an genau deswegen ist es garantiert was supersimples wahrscheinlich auch wahrscheinlich
den powerknopf nicht richtig angeschlossen oder sowas
irgendwie sowas ok so dann gucken wir mal was er sagt
er sagt nix es geht es ist angegangen gerade habt ihr es gesehen ich hatte irgendwas nicht
richtig drin stecken easy ich hatte irgendwas nicht richtig drin stecken
ich habe gerade noch mal alle kabel raus und wieder rein gemacht und jetzt gehts dann hätte
ich mir das mit der gpu ersparen können oder und leute wo sind jetzt die haarrisse auf
dem mainboard die entstehen durchliegen wie stand da dinge nicht dass es an der gpu liegt
ne ich hatte gpu eben draußen und hab dann noch mal versucht einzuschalten das ging nicht
chat seid ihr erleichtert dass es angeht
also ich ja auch ein bisschen ich hab schon gedacht hä was soll jetzt sein aber
die gpu beim ausbauen hat sie haben sich die haarrisse wieder selbst gefixt ja korrekt
obviusly
endlich hab ich mal ne erklärung dafür woran es liegt
na klar
gut jetzt startet windows das bringt mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich viel dass windows
startet
worst case wäre gewesen ja ich zerstöre mein 5000 euro pc aber ganz ehrlich so viel
verdiene ich mit keinem youtube video
ja das stimmt schon aber wir haben das ding liegen da gibt es also das ding hat keine
risse vom liegen bekommen ich weiß nicht was ihr alle mit euren rissen habt das liegt die
ganze zeit ist nicht so als hängt die grafikkarte dran
okay haben wir wieder ausgeschaltet okay mal gucken ob das jetzt reproduzierbar ist ja
ich mach jetzt ich mach jetzt das netzteil aus
ja zukünftig was anderes so jetzt mach ich das netzteil wieder an
okay es geht also in der config ist kein problem zu sehen
gut dann machen wir wieder aus und ich baue die grafikkarte ein chat was sagt ihr eigentlich
also ich mach das netzteil aus aber was meint ihr kann man die in der grafikkarte tauschen
wenn das netzteil wenn das system aus ist aber die grafikkarte aber das netzteil eingeschaltet
ist ich mach das nicht ich will es nur von euch wissen
ich mach das netzteil aus aber kann man das machen könnte man das machen
also wie gesagt netzteil an mainboard hat noch strom
ich mach das nicht ich mach keine sorge ich mach das nicht
ich überlege gerade ob ich das netzteil kann ich das netzteil irgendwie wartet mal
ne ihr bleibt jetzt nicht stehen noch mal testen ob es wieder angeht oder
ob das netzteil vielleicht einen wackelkontakt hat oder sowas
nö juckt ihr nicht geht einfach
ich mach jetzt die grafikkarte wieder rein netzteil aus
da muss ich das temporär da muss ich das jetzt noch mal hier rein stellen
weil einbauen geht ja nicht da muss ich das gehäuse rumdrehen
ist halt dumm ne richtig ist halt richtig dumm dass ich hier keinen platz hab
so kann ich das lasen alles klar grafikkarte wo bist du fettes ding
pepo fett ich ich werde es jetzt nicht runter stellen
moment moment moment moment klipse auf das da muss weg
gehst du weg komisches komisches kabel da
das ist geklipst man sieht halt mal wirklich gar nichts alter
ja ja ich glaube ist drin wo hab ich die teile
musik geht ab ja
ja die hängt also die hängt tatsächlich ein bisschen ja
das ist tatsächlich nicht so ohne aber die hängt eher die hängt eher nach
hinten als nach unten
ok wo ist mein schraubschrauber schraubchamp
ok jetzt schau doch ob es geht bevor du die anschraubst
ich muss die zumindest mit einer anschrauben weil
das ist schlicht und ergreifend zu schepp wenn ich die nicht festschraube die ist zu
schwer also zumindest mit einer muss ich die festschrauben
so willst du das mal ausprobieren was macht der
was macht der wenn die grafikkarte nicht richtig drin steckt
sie geht nicht an
sie geht nicht an ok ja damit war zu rechnen
damit war zu rechnen damit ja ich wollte mal gucken was passiert
wenn das stromkabel nicht drinne steckt ok jetzt muss ich dieses hässliche riesen stromkabel
wieder einschließen also ich brauche unbedingt den adapter
kurzer pleck ja ich war es ich war es leute
ist halt wirklich dumm dass sie hier das so ein fettes dieses fette ding da braucht man
nicht so rum clips ok man muss wirklich bis es clips macht
sonst wird das nix die karte brennt erst unter last wenn überhaupt
also ich habe alles richtig reingeklipsed ok
alles drin alles dran ok ok man was eine scheiß konstruktion alter
das ist richtig hängen geblieben das ist richtig hängen geblieben ok
es lebt
um nicht zu sagen ok da hat kein bock mehr zu leuchten ich
müsste netzwerkabel dran kriegen irgendwie netzwerkabel und power an switch dass wir
uns darauf einlocken können mapper per ldp probiere mal ob ich ein ob ich strom an switch
bekomme weil direkt grafikkarte anschließend habe ich kein als echt kein kein nerv dafür
einfach per ldp gucken ja ich habe keinen platz also wir ziehen gerade
86 watt beim starten
ich krieg nicht switch und zeugs zusammentran ich hab zu wenig stecker leute
noch mal kurz runterfahren
das ist auch cool wie das ausfaded ne
gesicht wurde nicht geleakt
herausforderung ist ich muss dieses strom kabel irgendwie noch reinkriegen das geht
da muss ich aber das da muss ich das ok leute
ich muss kurz das ring light ausmachen ist auch besser für die für die für die bessere
rgb six hat time
lüfter sind auch gar nicht angeschlossen vom gehäuse wie gesagt das kann ich hier
nicht zusammen mit euch man muss das gehäuse permanent hin und her hin und her drehen
volle rgb experience
warum leuchtet das da rot
das leuchtet rot ist das gut oder schlecht dass das da rot leuchtet
das leuchtet rot leuchtet gut oder schlecht
ich guck mal kurz in meinem dhcp alarm
ich muss mal kurz in meinem dhcp gucken
was ich das ding von der ip zieht
ip server leases desktop aha
ok yes
alles klar leute wir sind wir sind wir sind da
hw info einfach mal so weil es geht
cute chat so was haben wir denn hier wir haben eine also ne das cpu
video adapter gforce da ist sie
was sagt mir resizeable airbar state disabled
ist das jetzt was auch immer wahrscheinlich weil der treiber nicht installiert ist
guckt euch mal wie viele cpu kerne alle kann man den bios anschalten ich kann jetzt nicht
ins bios wenn ich jetzt ins bios gehe
leute wollt ihr mal sehen wie schnell sich das dreht unter volllast
aber wobei ihr seht man sieht man in der kamera wahrscheinlich nicht
ja ich mach mal ich mach mal kurz scene bench scene bench scene bench
wie immer man das richtig ausspricht an
und dann seht ihr mal wie es wie es hoch dreht
treiber nicht vergessen
bam jetzt gibt es volle pulle leute scene bench
jetzt jetzt geht es ab
jetzt blutsch da und jetzt raus da ist raus da auch ein bisschen
warum ist die grafikkarte eigentlich warum ist die hier rot
hat es hier irgendeinen sinn dass sie da unten rot ist
wie es normal ja anscheinend
also wir sind relativ warm aber noch vollkommen in ordnung
kann das mal weg gehen was ist das hier für komisches
was was macht hw info da also wir sind bei
ja 90 grad also außerhalb vom case außerhalb vom case
waren wir bei 85 86 und innerhalb vom case sind wir ein bisschen
wärmer anscheinend
nee nee das ist vollkommen in ordnung bei der cpu
die trosselt sich erst ab 100 grad
stromverbrauch ich hab es jetzt nicht dran
du kannst bei mir auf twitter gucken also
350 watt oder so dürfte das jetzt haben
steht doch hier unten auch irgendwas oder cpu hat alleine
also cpu hat alleine 270 aber das ist natürlich nicht so ganz richtig
wenn ich das jetzt messen würde mit so einem zwischenstecker
dann wären wir jetzt irgendwie bei 350 oder sowas
also da geht was da geht was
353 steht auf twitter ja das war in der konfiguration 353
also wir haben ungefähr zwei bis drei grad mehr
im gehäuse als wenn es offen da steht
und es liegt jetzt auch ein bisschen doof also mal gucken
das ist in ordnung es ist ja auch hier unrealistisch
okay nice
hab ich jetzt beendet ja gut damit kann man gut die pude heizen
das stimmt
sieht aber doch ganz nett aus
warum leuchtet es da unten orange hat es was zu sagen
man weiß es nicht
schon mal hast du powermax benutzt nee
ja ich habe hier keine strommesser und granat das machen wir dann
so jetzt muss ich erstmal wieder das
jetzt muss ich mir das ring light einschalten
bist du ich habe schon geben schmack muss man bei mir auf twitter gucken
jetzt jetzt checken wir noch mal kurz
ob ich das gehäuse wirklich nur falls angeschlossen hatte
ich habe jetzt ausgeschaltet also nicht wundern
weil ich habe jetzt hier mein spezial power button
mal gucken ob ich es einfach nur verkehrt dran hat und es hier ohne ist reset
ja ich würde gerne was sehen chat das wäre nice
sehen wäre poc
okay ich hatte irgendwas verkehrt angeschlossen
ich hatte vorhin irgendwas nicht richtig eingestöpselt am netzteil
es waren wahrscheinlich die haarrisse im netzteil glaube ich
das meint ihr
vielleicht hat sich der chat ja geirrt und die waren nicht im mainboard sondern die waren
im netzteil
ist resizeable bar support an ich hab keine ahnung
das kann ich jetzt auch nicht gucken weil ich da für die capturecard oder monitor
und tastatur anschließen müsste gut also das funktioniert ja im prinzip
es wäre cool zu wissen zum beispiel wofür der button hier ist
ja jetzt so ein button den seht ihr jetzt nicht ich guck mal hier
da ist da ist so ein button dran aber das handbuch von der grafikkarte sagt ja
gar nichts
sv3 steht da nur dran für was ist sv3 man weiß es nicht
man hat keine ahnung
mal draufdrücken
da kannst du bios zwischen style und performance wechseln
okay
aha
interessant das wusste ich nicht
dass man zu aber das kann man auch bestimmt auch irgendwie über ein treiber machen
und wobei über ein treiber ist wahrscheinlich schwierig wenn du rebooten musst
chat ich fürchte remote desktop ist kaputt gegangen
ich fürchte das war es jetzt was wir zusammen im stream machen können glaube ich weil
jetzt muss ich das gehäuse umdrehen hinten die kabel verlegen
und das vorne alles richtig einstöpseln und so
das ist mir jetzt zu anstrengend im stream ehrlich gesagt ich muss das gehäuse hier
mehrfach müsste ich dann hoch und runter heben
rumdrehen da habe ich jetzt echt keinen bock drauf
wir können die grafikkarte noch festschrauben
gibt es eine liste mit hardware ja
ausruhe zeichen pc
ich muss jetzt immer aufpassen dass ich hier nicht gegen die gegen die kamera komme
massive katze
ist bestimmt sauer dass ich die ganze zeit die tür zu hab sobald ich hier fertig streamen
bin kommt die wahrscheinlich gleich rein
so geil wenn man nichts sieht
nichts zu sehen hier
ich schraube gerade über die kamera ja
wieso ich mich für die soltech entschieden habe ganz einfach weil es die einzige war
die gerade zu dem zeitpunkt halbwegs lieferbar war
haben wir die grafikkarte dran geschraubt wisst ihr eine sache will ich noch ausprobieren
eine sache will ich noch ausprobieren ob ob open rpg funktioniert nicht rpg rgb rpg
wäre das wäre das andere
ob man die ob man die rgb steuern steuern kann das habe ich nämlich auf github gefunden
und das wollte ich mal ausprobieren das können wir noch zusammen machen weil wir haben ja
alles angeschlossen jetzt was was rgb macht
aber das noch mal ausprobieren
bisschen bisschen rgb stellts probieren wir das noch mal
ich muss das ring light wieder raus machen weil da switch reingemacht werden muss
kann ich es vielleicht so machen irgendwie geht das
ich kriege beides rein porgu
hier findet sich noch was zur halterung und lichtlast
ich brauche mal was entspannteres gerade
neues bios für die grafikkarte ok
ich switch euch mal kurz um
ist ja auch geil dass du damit das nicht findest auf der anderen seite
das ist ok wenn ich an die grafikkarte
in den rgb in den led streifen anschließen will
ja nee das braucht man nicht
das brauche ich nicht und das ist gpu supports stand quick guide
also von außen machen die das ok
deswegen will ich ja auch deswegen will ich ja auch das gar nicht machen mit der software
sondern das probieren wir jetzt mal
alter chrome please google
open rgb ist das die offizielle seite ok open rgb.com ist die rechtseite
supported devices download windows 64 spit
download open rgb pipeline
mal gucken ob stable oder nicht
ich habe das noch nie verwendet ich hoffe das hat ein ui
ok open rgb
open rgb aber ich muss das bestimmt als admin starten oder
wow
code execution cannot process reinstall program
nice
sehr gut
muss ich das als admin vielleicht run
erstmal random sachen aus dem internet als admin ran
feelsgoodman
nein
ok
excellent funktioniert
entpacken
ach moment das ist ein zip
ist das ein zip
wait a minute
nee das ist doch schon entpackt
ich muss bestimmt irgendwas irgendwas installieren dafür dass es funktioniert
install
oh god ich sag saun man
das muss ich installieren
ich muss den saun ausmachen sonst dreh ich am rad
warum windows 11 weil nur der windows 11 scared jula so viele kerne und diese unterschiede
zwischen performance und efficiency oder energy course ich glaube efficiency course
kennt
windows 10 kann das nicht also wenn du das optimale rausholen willst mit der cpu dann
musst du
windows 11 verwenden also im prinzip genauso wie ich es gesagt habe in einem video von
mir
dass microsoft es schon so machen wird dass wir mehr oder weniger an der zeit umsteigen
wann war denn das release sieht man das hier vor einer vor einer woche
wurde gibt es dieses release vor einer woche oder was sagt uns das hier ja eine woche
ok
ah jetzt läuft's ok nice warning fail to initialize lgb dera module sensor
und wenn das ist wie körper bei a failure jetzt muss ich muss ich muss als administrator
starten ok
i don't know what to do
ich weiß nicht mal welche um welche sonst hier überhaupt geht
led bottom und top moment es hat top und bottom leds
ich sehe nur die unteren
please click this link
nee ich hab on board vier leds das war's ich hab das link ich hab das link geklickt
das link geht nicht auf
so ähm schauen wir mal ob wir da jetzt was umstellen kann chet
ich lass es mal so
safe and close so und ich sollte es noch mal runnen als admin
ach jetzt verstehe ich das glaube ich
ich glaube hier das ist nicht was on board ist sondern was da drüber angeschlossen
ist
äh boah keine ahnung
size was weiß ich was da rein muss
hier
ich schreib deswegen was hin
ok jetzt ich switch ich switch mal kurz auf das kamerabel jetzt gucken wir ob da was passiert
ok jetzt ist alles blau
außer das so tech ding das macht irgendwie was es will
jetzt stelle ich die mal auf rot
ah habt ihrs gesehen
ok ich hab meine settings sind auf jeden fall falsch
meine settings sind falsch
aber aber es scheint es scheint zu funktionieren
mach ich mal grün
ok das steuert die leds oben vom links und unten auf dem mainboard ok das funktioniert
schon mal
also hier unten die leds werden gesteuert die seht ihr nicht richtig hier unten sind
leds
und da oben also jetzt ist grün
mach mal kurz aus da seht ihrs wahrscheinlich besser
pink
ah its pink jetzt nochmal gelb
ich glaube du musst das rgb kabel vom mainboard zur gpu verbinden
also laut dem handbuch ist das kabel an der gpu nur dafür da
dass man
einen led strip anschließen kann
also also ich hab es hier schon mal auf jeden fall falsch eingestellt
rescan lieber heißt es
also machen wir mal 16
ich weiß wirklich nicht was ich da einstellen muss das ist mein problem
ah guck mal jetzt ist alles gelb
ok super nice
jetzt ist pink
und pink und gelb
ok wahrscheinlich sinds 32
das muss ich erstmal angucken wie man das berechnet da hab ich jetzt keinen plan von
wie das geht
haben wir schon admin getestet ja ja das ging jetzt
auch gleich
vielleicht muss ich da 32 reinschreiben
ok grün
oh ne jetzt kaputt kacke
jetzt machts nix mehr
ok das muss ich mir mal gucken wie man das berechnet ich hab keinen plan
ja oder auch wie man da mehrere was kann man hier sagen enteyer device name for led 1
all zones
ah jetzt sind die auf mainboard blau und das sind die unterschiedlichen ok das ist led
anschluss 1 led anschluss 2 auf mainboard und das sind die on board leds
verstehe verstehe
ok also das ist jetzt nicht so das ist jetzt relativ easy da kann man jetzt ok ich schalte
euch mal wieder um
kann ich euch wieder hier umschalten seht ihr jetzt seht ihr jetzt wieder was
also hier hab ich gerade drin rum gebastelt die meisten fps unterschiedlich
liegt in jeweiligen tagesform wie kann ich da drüber jetzt meine grafikkarte steuern
geht das überhaupt
gucken wir mal open rgb so tech trinity aha aha
was ist für ne software alter monkaS
ok die grafikkarte kann man da drüber anscheinend nicht steuern
meine grafikkarte kann man noch nicht da drüber steuern ganz ehrlich juckt mich nicht
ok grafikkarte ist anscheinend noch nicht steuerbar
afterburner kann ich steuern keine ahnung ist mir ehrlich gesagt doch wurscht
supported devices das kenne ich das ist aber nicht so wirklich aussagekräftig da steht
nicht jedes einzelne grafikkarte und sachen drauf sondern wenn wenn das jeweilige protokoll
unterstützt wird dann geht's ja du findest mein mainboard zum beispiel
auch nicht in der liste und trotzdem geht's ja da macht jeder hersteller sein eigenes
süppchen
mal ein windows update wie macht man überhaupt ein windows update
check for updates so
download und install check for updates ja gib ihm
ja soltech steht auch nirgends das interessiert mich nicht leute es ist mir wirklich vollkommen
egal ob ich die grafikkarte des rgb habe ich eigentlich nur gekauft wisst ihr was der einzige
grund ist warum ich rgb der rgb wasserkühlung habe der einzige grund ist weil das nur 5
euro teurer war als die nicht rgb wasserkühlung
oder dachte ich mir so ja scheiß drauf
mal nvidia.com alle ich suche nvidia.com über official driver will ich haben 5 euro verschwendet
schon irgendwo ja 4090 windows 11 game ready driver studio driver was ist was ich will
game ready driver
yes search game ready for portal was auch
ach nee da muss man sich doch jetzt registrieren dass es funktioniert ne ich hab meinen account
jetzt nicht hier
813mb ja weil das weil da dreimal in den browser included ist und sowas
dieses ganze overlay zeug das ist alles irgendwelche browser geschichten kein wunder dass das
alles so groß ist und die müssten ja heutzutage auch nix mehr sparen
portal ax muss dem stream zeigen ja rtx kann ich kann ich tatsächlich mal ne gute idee
ich muss übrigens windows eh neu installieren ne
ich wobei nee muss ich nicht zwangsläufig ich muss veracrypt machen und die die system
ssd verschlossen wir machen mal ssd wie hieß dieses ding noch mal ssd benchmark dieses
dieses viereckige mit den mit diesen viereckigen grünen buttons
crystal mark war das crystal mark
chip wir laden das jetzt von chip runter perfekt wenn schiff das sagt da bin ich dann
kann ich
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein nein conhe centrifuge
gibt's das bei heise vielleicht? naja. das da? den da meine ich, genau. heise, wie?
der kriege! der erste link ist der offizielle ja mittlerweile traue ich der sache schon nicht
mehr bei google ergebnissen. der kriege. so da ist es. nein. so viel?
so warten wir mal kurz bis der grafikkartentreiber installiert ist. wie gesagt wir sind nur bei
rdp drinnen da macht das mit der grafikkarte jetzt eh nicht so viel. mal kurz mal kurz
warten bis der grafikkartentreiber installiert ist und dann dann gib ihm. oh wir haben rdp gefickt
leute. launch gfors experience. nein will jetzt keine gfors erfahrung haben. wir haben
es kaputt gemacht. ok crystal mark. ah wenn der unterschied ist. er ist natürlich als
admin was sonst. ok c doppelpunkt. wir wollen eigentlich. ach für arm. flutscht. flutscht
würde ich sagen. flutscht. 7 gigabyte. passt alles in den cache? ja wir können es größer
machen. das ganze ding ist quasi ein einziger cache. äh mal was anderes. ach random das
ist das wo ssd's oftmals richtig gut sind. komm wir machen jetzt mal 4g und das ganze
nur einmal. ah scheiß drauf da gehts bisschen schneller. oder was komm. 8. wenn du den driver
samsung magician installierst. ach was. da brauchst du immer noch mehr was du updaten
musst und alles. was muss da noch schneller gehen. das ist so krass. schnell. das flutscht
echt richtig. die pci express lanes klühen. ja. und rgb. meine uhr. ja die ist ein bisschen
verkehrt. wahrscheinlich die falsche zeitzone. wollen wir mal hw info gucken wie warm die
ist. wir lassen ihn gerade nochmal kurz. ich lasse den ersten schreibtest noch durchlaufen.
der heatsink. naja aktuell hat er im gehäuse kaum lüfterfluss. crystal disk info. kann
das nicht. hw info. hw info kann das bestimmt auch. start. wieso was sagt denn samsung offiziell
was die kann. cpu. ddr5. samsung hier. drive temperature.
wieso ich hab doch mehr als was die beworben. achso ne hab ich nicht. naja. das eine ist
mip das andere ist mb. so guck mal wie warm das ding wird. so wir können doch den da
einfach machen. wir machen jetzt mal 64 g nur den da. juckt ihr nicht. ride ist nur halb
so viel. ja das ist komisch ne. sollte ride und lesen nicht ziemlich gleich schnell sein.
oh wie ist das. vielleicht wirklich dreiber für optimierung. aber erstmal wichtig dass
das ding ordentlich zusammengebaut krieg jetzt. jetzt ist ok jetzt ist ok. jetzt ist alles
in ordnung. schon besser. ist das nennenswert warm geworden? nö oder? kann man ihm sagen
dass der. ach hier nvme ssd muss man auch sagen. ah ok. peak performance. ok moment
jetzt machen wir nochmal acht und machen den nochmal. nur sieben gigabyte die sekunde
resident sleeper. nö macht keinen unterschied. die temperatur juckt ihn auch nicht. naja.
weißte ganz ehrlich kann ich mit leben. vielleicht installier ich noch die dreiber dafür aber
das ist erstmal in ordnung. was die cpu macht? na wahrscheinlich schreibanforderungen schicken.
also nullen schreiben oder so. oder einsen schreiben oder was macht er? schreibt er nullen
oder einsen. doch eben irgendwas gesehen settings. random ja da kein wunder dass die cpu erstmal
was machen muss. muss erstmal nach gigabyte random file irgendwo erzeugen. ok ich switch
nochmal rüber. switcherino. mach nochmal kurz das bastellicht an. also was ich jetzt
machen werde ist ohne euch ich schließe wahrscheinlich noch ein paar gehäuse lüfter an. die sind
nämlich hier aber so dass man nicht rankommt. die müsste man quasi hier unten rausholen.
hier haben wir gehäuse lüfter. wo die anderen gehäuse lüfter sind weiß ich nicht. die
müsste ich mal suchen wo die rumgammeln. ah da hinten. nee keine ahnung. und dann schließe
ich die nämlich noch an und dann mache ich mal zu und baue das netzteil ein. aber das
mache ich ohne euch. weil dann muss ich das ding hoch und runter heben und so habe ich
keinen bock drauf. gaming stream later. ich bin jetzt echt kaputt. ich weiß gar nicht
wie das leute den ganzen tag schaffen so mit facecam und allem zu streamen. fand das mega
anstrengend. chat ich hoffe euch hat es trotzdem gefallen. auch wenn natürlich die haarrisse
im mainboard wahrscheinlich in zukunft mir noch viel probleme machen werden. guck grad
ob es irgendjemand gibt den ich hosten kann. was ist denn das hier. live kanäle. du folgst
live kanäle ja zeig her. ja asmongold den muss ich nicht hosten. der hat irgendwie 8000
zuschauer oder so. ich könnte einen dark streamer hosten. der ist wahrscheinlich komplett
fertig mit den nerven wenn ich ihn hoste. da könnt ihr euch mal das beste mmo aller
zeiten angucken. der ist fertig mit den nerven. der hat normalerweise 5 zuschauer. lul. was
ist das? dark streamer. das ist das mmo was ich spiele. so nebenbei. richtig 20 jahre
altes mmo. der ist ein englischsprachiger streamer. ich guck den manchmal die letzten
tage über was mit leveln ist. sag ihm hallo. ich komm jetzt nicht mit rüber. wahrscheinlich
ist er fertig mit den nerven gleich wenn er den raid zieht. okay leute wir sehen uns
bis dann. machts gut co.